N
FORD.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN OF THROWING
UNITY OUT OF THE WINDOW.
READ AHEAD HEAD WITH DIVISIVE
MIDTERM STRATEGY SAYING THAT THE
REPUBLICANS THREATEN OUR
DEMOCRACY AND THE PHILOSOPHY
WITH FASCISM.
SIGNALS A MORE AGGRESSIVE
APPROACH AS BIDEN GETS READY TO
EMBARK ON NATIONWIDE TRAVEL AND
APPARENTLY A BLITZ.
71 DAYS UNTIL ELECTION DAY AND
THE DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL
COMMITTEE CHAIR SEEMS TO BE ON
BOARD.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID HE
SHOULD NOT VIEW EACH OTHER AS
ADVERSARIES IN THIS COUNTRY BUT
AS NEIGHBORS AND WE SHOULD TREAT
EACH OTHER WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT.
HELP US IN MY FASCISM A LABEL
FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY FIT
WITH THE INAUGURAL ADDRESS?
>> THE ONE THING THAT
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN HAS
ALWAYS BEEN CONSISTENT.
AND HE HAS ALWAYS BEEN SOMEBODY
WHO DOES WHAT MY GRANDFATHER
USED TO DO, WHICH IS SPEAK IT
PLAIN.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN YOU EMBRACE SEMI
SEMI FASCISM.
LET'S CALL WHAT IT IS WHAT IT IS
SPIRITS BEFORE HIS NEW TONE NOT
SITTING WELL WITH NEW HAMPSHIRE
AND USUALLY RESERVED FOR
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR.
>> HE IS TRYING TO STIR UP
ANTI-REPUBLICAN SENTIMENT BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
IT IS HORRIBLY INAPPROPRIATE AND
INSULTING.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE INSULTED.
HE SHOULD APOLOGIZE.
>> Dana: WATCH THIS EVEN
THOUGH THE MEDIA IS QUESTIONING
THE TACTIC.
>> THERE IS NO BACKPEDALING ON
THIS.
THERE IS A CLEAR AGGRESSIVE
STRATEGY THAT PARENTS HAVE
DEMOCRATS AND JUICES UP THE BASE
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SEE HIM BE
MORE AGGRESSIVE.
BUT IT DOES BECOME PROBLEMATIC
BECAUSE THIS IS THE GUY THAT
SAYS HE WANTS TO UNIFIED.
>> Dana: HERALD THE PRESIDENT
SIGNED THE INFLATION REDUCTION
ACT IN TOO MUCH FANFARE BUT GAS
PRICES HAVE TICKED DOWN AND THEN
HE DECIDED TO BASICALLY BAILED
OUT SEVERAL THOUSAND MILLION
PEOPLE WITH STUDENT LOANS.
HE TOPPED IT OFF WITH THIS
COMMENT ABOUT MAGA REPUBLICANS
BEING SEMI FASCISM.
THAT IS A STRATEGY AND EVERYBODY
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE IS USING
THIS LANGUAGE.
DO THEY HAVE SOME FOCUS THAT
THIS WILL BE A REAL WINNER?
>> Harold: I DON'T KNOW.
[LAUGHTER]
DANA, YOU SAID SOMETHING A WEEK
AGO AND I THINK IT WAS A WEEK
AGO RIGHT AFTER INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT WAS SIGNED.
YOU SAID IF YOU WERE ADVISING
THE PRESIDENT, YOU DON'T KNOW
WHY HE WOULD GO BACK TO
DELAWARE.
HE SHOULD HAVE GONE ON THE ROAD
AND PROMOTED IT.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE DONE.
I THINK IT WOULD HAVE ALLOWED
FOR A DIFFERENT KIND OF ENTRY
INTO THE POLITICAL SEASON.
WE ARE TWO MONTHS AWAY.
I THINK PRESIDENT BIDEN IS ON
THE RECEIVING END OF ACT THE
LAST FEW MONTHS AND PRETTY
INTERESTING VERBAL ATTACKS AND
CHARACTERIZATIONS OF HIS
PRESIDENCY.
HE'S GOING TO GIVE A LITTLE BIT
BACK AND WE SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED BY THAT.
I THINK YOU THINK ABOUT
PRESIDENTS IN THE
PAST, PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS CALLED
A SOCIALIST, A
TERRORIST, SOMEONE NOT BORN IN
THE UNITED STATES AND END UP
SERVING FOUR YEARS OF AN
EIGHT-YEAR PRESIDENCY.
THIS IS POLITICS.
THIS DOES GO AGAINST THE BRAIN
BECAUSE PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
RUNNING AND I THOUGHT HE GAVE
ONE OF THE GREAT SPEECHES WHEN
HIS INAUGURAL ADDRESS
ACCENTUATED AND AMPLIFIED THESE
POINTS.
HERE WE ARE IN A NEW SEASON AND
IT WILL GET MESSIER.
WE HAVE HAD REPUBLICANS SAY
THINGS ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT ONE THING IT THAT IS
CONCERNING, JUDGE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN...
MY FRIENDS WITH INCREDIBLE
ENERGY OF LOVE AND UNITY COMING
TOWARDS ME.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE FOUND
THE POLLING DATA SHOWS US IS
THAT THE ONLY PERSON WHO WAS
MORE DIVISIVE ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL THAN PRESIDENT BIDEN IS
PRESIDENT, FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO WE SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED THE
PARTIES WILL TRY TO USE A LITTLE
BIT OF THIS AS THEY GET
GOING.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT FARES.
HE MAY BE PUNISHED BECAUSE HE
WANTED TO BE A UNIFIER OR AS
PETER ALEXANDER SAID IN A
CLIP, HE GETS ENERGIZED AND
MIDTERMS ARE ABOUT ENERGIZING.
>> IS THIS HIS DEPLORABLES
MOMENT, JUDGE?
IT IS PEER TO FOLLOW UP ON WHAT
HAROLD SAID.
THIS IS THE GUY THAT WANTS TO BE
A UNIFIER IS WHAT ALEXANDER SAID
APPEARED WHAT JOE BIDEN DID IT
STARTED THIS RHETORIC THAT WAS
SO INSULTING THAT HE SHOULD
REMEMBER 73 MILLION OR
74 MILLION AMERICANS VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
HE SHOULD ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT IN
THE PRIMARIES, IN THE PRIMARIES
BEFORE THE
MIDTERMS, DONALD TRUMP TAP ON
THE SHOULDER OF THE CANDIDATE
WAS FOR MANY OF THEM THE
WINNING NOD THAT THEY NEEDED.
I THINK IT IS SHEER STUPIDITY TO
DO THAT, BUT WORSE THAN THAT.
THIS IS HATRED.
FASCISM IS SOMETHING THAT
AMERICANS HATE APPEAR TO
CONNECTED WITH WORLD WAR II, MY
FATHER FOUGHT IN WORLD WAR II
AND WE CONNECT THAT WITH
PEOPLE KILLING
AMERICANS, FIGHTING FOR FREEDOM.
WE DON'T DO THAT BECAUSE, YOU
KNOW, HATRED AND THIS KIND OF
RHETORIC LEADS TO VIOLENCE.
THAT IS THE WAY IT IS.
HATE IS HATE.
HATE LEADS TO VIOLENCE AND
VIOLENCE LEADS TO RETALIATION.
NOW, THE LEFT MAY DECIDE THEY
NEED TO JAM THINGS UP AND THEY
WANT TO SEE JOE BIDEN GET A
LITTLE MORE EXCITED WITH 56%
OF THE DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT
BIDEN TO RUN FOR REELECTION.
SO THIS IS HOW THE GUY WHO
APPARENTLY LIED WHEN HE SAID HE
WANTED TO BE THE UNIFIER AND THE
ADULT IN THE ROOM, THIS IS
HOW HE'S GETTING JAMMED UP BY
HITTING THE OTHER SIDE APPEAR
THAT IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M TIRED TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU WHAT THEY SAID
ABOUT OBAMA.
WE ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT OBAMA.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
JOE BIDEN CALLED AT LEAST
75 MILLION AMERICANS WHO VOTED
AND A HELL OF A LOT MORE THAT
DIDN'T.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING AS
THE HEAD OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, HE IS
BASICALLY GIVING THE GO-AHEAD TO
EVERYBODY ELSE ON THE PARTY TO
SAY SIMILAR THINGS.
HERE IS COLORADO SECRETARY OF
STATE JANET GRISWOLD.
SHE SAID, SHE CLAIMS AMERICANS
COULD LOSE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE
WITHIN MONTHS IF THE REPUBLICANS
RAN THE ELECTIONS, JOEY.
>> Joey: LOOK AT GEORGIA,
JIM CROW 2.0 OR THE BECAUSE
VOTER TURNOUT IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW YOU LOOK AT
IT.
IF YOU ARE REPUBLICANS, I DOUBT
A LOT OF LIBERALS AND JOE BIDEN
IN WASHINGTON RIGHT NOW, HOPE
SO, HOPE YOU ARE TUNING IN TO
LEARN BUT IF NOT DON'T GET
OUTRAGED.
DON'T GET OFFENDED, BE
VINDICATED.
HE IS SHOWING YOU THAT HIS TRACK
RECORD OF SAYING RACIST THINGS
AND COHERENT THINGS, DIVISIVE
THINGS IS ABSOLUTELY INTACT.
DON'T LET HIM REALIZE HOW BAD IT
IS.
LET HIM CONTINUE TO TALK FOR THE
NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS AND MAKE A
BUNCH OF COMMERCIALS AND ROLL
THEM OUT OCTOBER, EARLY
NOVEMBER.
IN WIN THIS MIDTERM AND WIN IT
STRONG.
THIS IS A COHERENT PLAN THEY PUT
TOGETHER.
THIS IS THEIR STRATEGY.
BACK TO TRUMP CANDIDATES IN THE
PRIMARIES, WHICH WE SAW AND DO
TO GET THE TRUMP CANDIDATES ON
THE BALLOT.
THEN YOU DO THIS CREATE NEGATIVE
HEADLINES BUYS SLOW ROLLING THE
JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE AND
MAR-A-LAGO, THE RAID WAS A PART
OF THIS.
PHASE 2 AND THE PHASE WHERE YOU
TRY TO CONVINCE THE COUNTRY THAT
SIMPLY BEING CONSERVATIVE IS
EQUIVALENT TO EVERY HORRIBLE
THING THEY HAVE EVER SAID ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
YOU TRY TO PUT IT IN ONE BASKET
OF DEPLORABLES.
>> Dana: WELL, WE ARE AT A
PHASE WHERE THE OPERATIVE
QUESTION IS WHAT BIDEN WON'T DO
TO GET FAR LEFT VOTERS
ENERGIZED?
>> NONE OF US TOOK HIM
SERIOUSLY.
MOST DAYS HE CANNOT COMPLETE A
SENTENCE IF WE ARE HONEST.
IT IS DISGUSTING BECAUSE WE
NEVER SEEN AN ATTACK ON A VOTE
OR PURE THEY DELIVERY ATTACK WAS
NOT SOMETHING SHE WANTED TO GET
OUT BUT WHEN IS SHE FELT THAT WT
SHE WASN'T AT A PUBLIC EVENT
THAT CAME OUT OF HER MOUTH.
FOR ALL THE DIVISIVE MYTHS FOR
TRUMP ATTACKING HIS MEDIA AND
OPPONENTS BUT NOT THE PEOPLE.
AND I THINK WHAT THIS SPEAKS TO
HEADING INTO THE MIDTERMS IS A
LACK OF DELIVERABLE.
THERE WAS NOTHING THEY CAN SAY
TO VOTERS TO MITIGATE THEIR LIFE
IS BETTER OFF NOW THAN IT WAS
TWO YEARS AGO, WHICH IS WHY
INSTEAD YOU'RE NOT GETTING
PEOPLE WHAT THEY DID WITH
INFLATION AND THE BORDER BECAUSE
IT IS TERRIBLE BUT INSTEAD ULTRA
MAGA AND I CAN'T BELIEVE IT IS
NOT MAGA.
WOULD YOU RUN ON THIS RECORD AND
KNOCK ON THE DOOR, INFLATION.
YOU LIKE FENTANYL OVERDOSE
DEATHS?
IT'S TERRIBLE!
>> Dana: IT WAS A WAY FOR THEM
TO GET ON OFFENSE AND BE
OFFENSIVE.
>> IT IS VERY OFFENSIVE AND IT
IS OFFENSIVE TO ME BECAUSE I
TALK TO THE MAGA FOLKS ON THE
RADIO EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE THE NICEST PEOPLE IN
THE WORLD AND THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT RIGHTS.
THEY DON'T WANT TO TAKE OVER
AWAY RIGHTS PEER THAT IS WHO
THEY A